former British intelligence officer
Christopher Steele and the former
British Military Intelligence officer
Philip Ingram good morning Christopher
good morning uh Philip good morning good
morning uh Christopher what do you make
of where we've got to this morning
um it seems was it all a lot of fuss
about nothing or has something changed
no I think something has changed and
what's changed I think is that the
Vladimir Putin has lost Authority and
legitimacy within Russia and has been
challenged in a way yes he's managed to
worm his way out of it for the for the
present but to see events unfold in
Russia yesterday and the speed with
which the situation seemed to spiral out
of control must be very concerning for
Putin and the people around him
uh
and uh so what do you think is it is the
takeaway here that Putin is weaker than
he was uh on Thursday
well I think that's one of the takeaways
definitely but the other bit that's
there is there's an awful lot we don't
know yet uh your pregosian won't have
done this in isolation
um he's achieved an awful lot you know
he's he's driven hundreds of kilometers
in less than 24 hours when it took him
um 18 months to fight through seven
kilometers inside Ukraine
um you know he has embarrassed shoigu by
getting a military capability that was
under Russian mod command allegedly I'm
taking it out and
um taking it into Russia capturing one
of Russia's largest cities bloodlessly
and then driving towards Moscow and
threatening the whole regime there's a
lot more to play out with this
let's assess who has most to worry about
about let's put put into one side for a
moment but um it sounds like we haven't
heard anything from shoigu or garasimov
the military leaders
um
does anybody think that they have
essentially uh been taken out of the
picture Christopher
it's too early to say yet but my strong
feeling would be that uh shoigu is
finished
um where the garasimov's survives is
another matter of course Putin doesn't
want to be seen to look weak by getting
rid of them in the immediate aftermath
of this debacle and it may take a few
weeks to play out but my guess would be
that joygu won't be defense minister for
that much longer and I'm really asking
about this because in the end the big
thing uh here Philip is what will it
mean for the war in Ukraine does this
give ukrainians a little bit of an edge
or is it something that makes no
difference or as Diana Magnum might have
been was suggesting earlier on that
actually it means that there's somebody
competent and dangerous in Belarus now
who will add strength to Putin's hand
well the answer is yes to all of those
um in reality from a tactical
perspective is it affecting the
Ukrainian counter-offensive and the
Russian defense on the ground not really
you know the Russian soldiers that on
the ground are too interested in
protecting their own lives and saving
their own lives the ukrainians are still
having to fight through minefields that
are still there the tank traps that are
still there defensive lines that are
still there however where it does start
to help is when it comes to the wider
coordination uh that there is in the
support that's going into Ukraine and
the ability to plan forward because the
Russian military approach approach is a
very top-down approach orders come from
the very top and are executed at the
lowest levels there's no initiative
within that whatsoever so there's
creating confusion in there and the
ukrainians have got an opportunity here
they can add more confusion at an
operational level by destroying other
command and control headquarters
Logistics hubs lines of communication
which will cause the higher demand who
are confused by everything that's going
on and even bigger headache that gives
them a real opportunity that they can
exploit tactically on the ground but it
will take a few days or a week or so for
that to properly come through and so we
are in early days at the moment uh
Christopher let me ask you finally the
the usual unfair TV journalists uh
question
um look forward a year
will Putin still be there and looking
closer in the Horizon
um what can we do in this country or in
the west to make sure that uh that
balance tips uh in the way that the
ukrainians want
I think it's important to say first of
all that you know we shouldn't be
interfering in in Russian internal
politics to talk with the view to
toppling a regime however obviously we
want the Russians to withdraw from from
Ukraine and to become a more responsible
State I think the the main thing we can
do is try and ensure Ukrainian Victory
on the battlefield because I think that
is where this whole thing will be
decided in the end
thank you both for for your commentary
um we don't know what's going to happen
but no doubt we'll be on it all the time